[Music]
on valentine's day
1990 a camera shutter
clicks
[Music]
every photograph is unique but the image
captured at this particular moment
is unlike anything that's been seen
before
or will be seen again for many years to
come
it is of the earth from 6
billion kilometers away
the last glimpse of home for the voyager
1 space probe
venturing into the darkness never
to return voyager 1 has been on a grand
tour of the outer solar system since its
launch in 1977
it's flown past and photographed jupiter
and
saturn before heading out into
interstellar space
but before it leaves its onboard cameras
capture
a family portrait of six planets
including the earth
it beams back the images encoded in
radio
signals traveling at the speed of light
the signals take five and a half hours
to reach us
it's the last photo the probe takes
before its cameras
power down forever
this photo of the earth is not what you
might expect
diagrams of the solar system rarely show
the planets and their relative distances
to scale in voyager 1's image made up of
640
000 pixels our planet takes up less than
one
in this picture earth is nothing more
than a pale
blue dot this fraction of a pixel
contains every living thing that we know
of
from bacteria to blue whales it contains
endless marching forests and grassy
savannah
it contains more than 5 billion people
and their sprawling cities
on almost every continent
but from this far away all of this life
is invisible earth is a pale blue dot
a blur of deep blue oceans and white
clouds
from this far away our home appears as
empty
as the barren planets in our solar
system family
[Music]
but is this really true
is the evidence for life on our planet
so easily masked by mere distance
would our home pixel really look the
same
if life had never come about in the
first place
[Music]
on earth today living things surround us
they're in the rocks in the air in the
oceans
the planet is teeming with life
but as far as we have yet discovered
this is a rarity in the cosmos
is life really so unlikely
in 1953 german-born physician hubertus
stroghold
was contemplating the medical challenges
of space exploration
when he coined the term ecosphere
the ecosphere is a habitable zone around
a star
in which conditions are sufficiently
temperate for life
to thrive by venturing away from the
ecosphere
astronauts would find it incredibly hard
to survive
by definition earth sits within the
ecosphere
or habitable zone around our star but
since struggle's revelation
astrobiologists worldwide have tried to
identify the criteria for a planet
to become home to living things
of course these criteria are based on
what we know about terrestrial life
and basic chemistry that's the best we
can do
with a sample size of one
first the star must be suitable it must
be long enough lived to allow planets to
orbit with stable conditions
for a few billion years out of all the
stars in our galaxy
about 90 percent make the grade then the
star must have rocky planets orbiting
around it
solid surfaces help the chemical
reactions of life so although it's
possible for living things to be
entirely airborne
it is much more likely that life got
started on a solid
rocky surface not only that but in order
to sustain
life's chemistry the planet needs liquid
water on its surface
and an atmosphere that is neither too
thin nor too
thick and crushing to have a planet of
just the right size
orbiting within the habitable zone of
its star where it's the right
temperature for water to linger as a
liquid
is incredibly rare scientists estimate
between five
and fifty percent of sun-like stars will
have a planet
like that still in our galaxy alone
that leaves the potential for several
billion planets
just like the earth is life on these
planets
inevitable unfortunately that's not an
easy question to answer
we just don't know enough about the
early conditions on earth and the
chemical revolutions that led
to the first life we don't know if given
the right mix of chemicals
life sprang up spontaneously all over
the globe
or if it took a remarkable stroke of
luck in one
isolated pool in one corner of the
planet
with this huge unknown we can't say if
life is assured
or if it's one in a billion
but since the origin of life still
eludes us
there's a good chance that it's not easy
or inevitable dedicated scientists
still haven't recreated those earliest
living things
from non-living matter so maybe life on
earth
was in fact a fluke
[Music]
if life on earth came about because of a
lucky roll of the chemical dice
then it's much more likely that it never
started at all
how then would the planet have evolved
over 4 billion years
without life how different would it look
today people no cities
no birds in the sky no fish in the sea
no crawling insects
no plants no trees no grassy savannah no
mossy rocks
no seaweed on the shore
far from a world dorbed liberally with
green
we'd be faced with a hard harsh
landscape
of gray rocks and dark blue oceans
but the absence of life goes much deeper
than what we see on the surface
in fact some argue that there's nothing
at all on our planet that hasn't been
affected by living things
the surface itself is sculpted by life
plants from the most basic lichens to
the biggest trees
are routed to the land surface and
modify it
in turn root systems probe into the
finest cracks
take hold and tear solid stone into
shattered debris water penetrates the
surface of this new rubble
dissolving minerals which the plants
absorb in this way
the compositions of the rocks at the
surface are permanently altered
by biological weathering the result is a
new kind of material
which wouldn't exist at all without life
soil as well as the weathered rocks
soils contain an
abundance of organic matter too both
living and dead
so if life never evolved on earth
there'd be no soil on the surface today
instead the land surfaces of earth might
look more like those on the dusty red
planet
mars
although soils may seem like a minor
loss from our planet
this thin layer has had a major effect
on the shape and longevity of surface
features
because up to 50 percent of a soil is
made up of
voids empty space which can be filled
with water that helps the rock fragments
and organic matter
stay stuck together combined with the
root systems that form them in the first
place
soils are incredibly good at staying put
and protecting the unweathered rocks
beneath them
without soils we could say goodbye to
rolling hills
and valleys the landscape would be a
hard
harsh one of craggy mountains deep
gorgeous
and chaotic rock falls and landslides
altered
by vast tectonic forces and the
inexorable grind of water
wind and ice
the rocks exposed at the surface would
be fundamentally different too
if life had never arrived there would be
no
fossil shells or bones no coals oils or
natural gas either
around 10 percent of rocks exposed at
the surface today
are limestones formed from calcium
carbonate which
almost always has been created by living
things
mollusks corals and tiny plankton all
make their shells from calcium carbonate
without life there would be no white
chalk cliffs of dover
or marble quarries of the italian
dolomites
but it's not just the solid surfaces of
earth that life has transformed
living things have fundamentally altered
the planet's swaddling atmosphere too
before any life arrived on the early
earth the atmosphere was a concoction
brewed
in the belly of a volcano carbon dioxide
water vapor and methane all spewed from
the hellish molten landscape
of the hadian
but life and especially green life
changed all of that photosynthesis
which transforms water and carbon
dioxide into sugar and oxygen
using light as an energy source was a
revolution
for the earth's atmosphere this new
chemical pathway was seized with
further by living things about two and a
half billion years ago
the carbon dioxide that was so abundant
in the early atmosphere
was a bottomless feast for the first
green organisms
they absorbed it and excreted oxygen in
its place
and then they absorbed some more to
build their shells
creating limestone rock and so the
atmosphere
transformed from one dominated by carbon
dioxide and methane
to one rich in oxygen instead
had life never gained a foothold and
figured out photosynthesis
our atmosphere would be the same steamy
volcanic effusion
that reigned in the hadian dominated by
physical processes and spontaneous
chemical reactions
and indeed today a visitor to a lifeless
earth
would find an almost unrecognizable
planet
with a palette of colours closer to
venus or saturn's moon titan
than the blues and greens and whites
gifted us
by life without oxygen in the air it's
not available to react with surface
rocks and sediments
much of the red color we see in dunes
and in river deposits
is a result of iron minerals reacting
with oxygen
to make iron oxide or rust without life
to make the oxygen
to make the iron oxide the surface of
the planet
would be painted in little more than
shades of grey
without reactive oxygen methane can
stick around in the atmosphere too
and when sunlight hits methane it makes
hydrocarbons not enough for life
but enough to make a sickly orange haze
that fills the atmosphere with a
permanent
smog all over the surface of the earth
the sun would be veiled as if by some
approaching wildfire
or distant volcanic eruption
incredibly a lack of life also means a
lack of clouds too
the tiny creatures whose calcium
carbonate shells make up the white
cliffs of dover
also emit chemicals into the air that
helps water condense into droplets
and make clouds they're so abundant in
the oceans
that they're a major contributor to our
cloud cover
without them the planet may never be
graced with the wisps of white cirrus
or banks of fluffy cumulus instead
only an indistinct humid fog would lie
heavy beneath the overlying methane smog
in fact had life never modified our
atmosphere
the earth may have suffered a similar
fate to our planetary neighbor
venus carbon dioxide is a greenhouse gas
trapping the sun's heat close to the
surface with an atmosphere full of this
potent insulator surface temperatures
gradually rise until they reach truly
hellish levels the surface of venus
bakes at more than 450 degrees celsius
due in part to its thick blanket of co2
that could have been the earth without
life
it seems we may have life itself to
thank
for keeping our planet livable
[Music]
curious reliance of our planet's
habitability on its living inhabitants
was a paradox first noted by english
scientist
james lovelock in the 1970s
lovelock is something of a contemporary
polymath having worked in medicine
chemistry and environmental science
in the 1960s he considered how life
might be detected on mars
one of the most promising signatures
lovelock concluded was non-equilibrium
only life has the power to drive
atmospheres away
from chemical equilibrium just as on
earth reactive oxygen came to replace
carbon dioxide finding an atmosphere out
of balance
suggests an invisible hand at work
by extension he noted how the conditions
on the earth influence its biosphere
and how living things have the power to
affect the earth itself
on a long-term global scale
the result he saw was a self-regulating
system
that keeps conditions stable and
suitable for life
all over the planet a super organism of
sorts
on a planetary scale he named his theory
of a protective
self-sustaining feedback loop after the
greek goddess of earth
gaia and lovelock's gaia works in many
different ways
to unconsciously keep the earth
habitable
to demonstrate the power of a
self-preserving planetary superorganism
lovelock and others conceived of a
computer simulation of a theoretical
planet
which is home to two populations
of daisies black daisies
and white daisies it was called
daisy world
black daisies liked it when it was
cooler and white daisies when it was hot
in the planet's early days when the heat
from its young sun was weak
the black daisies thrive and cover the
planet
their dark colour helps to absorb the
sun's heat
soon it becomes warm enough for white
daisies to take over
their bright colour reflects rather than
absorbs the sun's energy
and the planet temperature drops black
daisies take over again
and eventually an equilibrium is reached
with both black and white daisies
helping to keep the planet's temperature
optimal for both populations
daisy world is an incredibly simple
model of a planetary feedback loop
and the earth is certainly a much more
complex system but
similar feedback loops have been
affecting conditions on the planet over
geological
time scales take for example the carbon
dioxide in our atmosphere
volcanoes emit carbon dioxide causing
levels of the gas to rise in the
atmosphere and increasing the thickness
of our warming blanket of gas
temperatures rise warm temperatures are
good for life in general
one need only to look at the tropical
rainforests to see how living things
thrive when it's warm so when the earth
is warmer plants grow faster and denser
and all these plants need carbon dioxide
to fuel their photosynthesis
so they draw it down from the atmosphere
and lock it away in their tissues
some is returned to the atmosphere but
much of it is sequestered away in the
long term
in other living things or in soils or in
the rocks themselves
by reducing the amount of carbon dioxide
in the atmosphere
and thinning the blanket of greenhouse
gas living things have ensured that the
earth
doesn't get too hot and there's a check
at the other end of the scale too
if carbon dioxide levels drop too low
the earth's temperature
will also drop colder ice-covered
landscapes aren't hospitable to life
so plants don't thrive there aren't
large populations to hoover up carbon
dioxide
so over time the gradual input from
volcanoes can boost levels
until temperatures start to rise again
in this way
carbon dioxide levels and temperatures
have fluctuated through much of earth's
history
moderated by living things regulation
by the guiding hand of gaia never sees
conditions
pushed too far
and guys mechanisms don't just see
temperatures maintained
the complex interaction of organic life
with the inorganic earth
helps to keep the chemistry of our
oceans in check too
helping salinity and acidity stay at the
same levels
for hundreds of millions of years
gaia's guiding hand has no consciousness
behind it
it is but a fortunate consequence of our
life's colonization
of earth it's this link that has kept
earth habitable
and inhabited for billions of years
an ecosystem that doesn't promote the
conditions of its own survival
is not destined to last long
[Music]
and yet in the last hundred years or so
humans
as the newest life form on the scene are
testing
gaia's ability to bounce back the
changes that we have wrought on our
planet have been faster
and more extreme than anything gaia has
yet faced
carbon dioxide levels have risen and
global temperatures
have soared it remains to be seen
whether our ecosystems can adapt
to compensate in time before the planet
[Music]
roasts
when voyager 1 pointed its cameras back
at the earth in 1990
it saw a blurry pale pixel
the life that graces our planet is
invisible
from 6 billion kilometers away but its
effects on the globe
are not that our oceans and clouds
persist
at all is a sign that temperatures are
still
optimal for surface water and that
is thanks to life and gaia
next time we will explore the
fascinating stories behind the first
fossils
and the origin of earth's magnetic field
[Music]
you've been watching the entire history
of the earth
like and subscribe and we'll see you
again soon